We've got sign up and login working.
So I think the next task is
to implement logging out.
I'd also like to implement what
happens when the user gets kicked off.
So when can a user be kicked off?
Well, usually when a user logs in they
don't stay logged in for ever and
ever and ever.
And you can actually control how long
Firebase will allow you to have a logged
in user via the dashboards session
length property right here.
Just get to it by clicking
on the login and off tab.
Selecting a value here
affects all forms of login.
I'm going to go ahead and
set this to one month.
Now being kicked off
is an automatic thing,
whereas logging out is something
that you choose to do.
But both of these two actions
should have the same effect.
And that is to clear the user data
out of shared preferences and
to take you back to the login activity.
Both of these actions will also
trigger an AuthStateListener.
So we can take the code
that does this and
put it inside of the AuthStateListener
and then we'll be set in both scenarios.
Now being kicked out because of
session time-out is something that
Firebase handles for you, but you're
going to need to hook up the login
button to have the correct behavior.
To log out a user you simply need
to get a Firebase reference and
call unauth on it.
That'll log out whatever user
is logged in on the client.
I've already written the log
out menu option for you.
You just need to make it visible.
And I'll send over more details
about that in the spec.
Hopefully that's enough
to get you started.
And good luck.